[Music]
so we're back Gary Chuck I want to talk
about a timeline of the universe I've
heard you talk about this nail and
you've sort of referenced it in the
Gridiron timeline of the Universe I
could do that yeah all right but then
I'm gonna make my way up to that because
there's a lot of ways I can get there
but totally that's where the timeline I
think in fact works best in the Gridiron
of the universe but we are mapping right
now with the James word telescope
and so it'll be fun to see I'll get to
that I have to do a quick calculation
before that but to find out what part of
the timeline of the universe is the
James Webb Telescope serving well that's
cool our Curiosities so can we take can
we bet on where uh
so here's how it goes you take the the
age of the universe
which is about 14 rounded to 14 billion
years okay and you can ask
how do you think about that how do you
yeah how do you measure that how do you
and so
nobody can get their mind around 14
million much less 14 billion exactly
yeah billion correct okay or 14 000 even
right 80 years we could never really
think about what 14
000 years are right right it's outside
of that's called Deep time and no one
even thought anything in the universe
was as old as that until relatively
recently right in the last 150 years or
so yeah so think of all of the history
of civilization and what our
understanding was about time part of the
problem is we think time intervals are
you know somehow
Cosmic time intervals somehow matter to
human time intervals right and they
don't
at all so the universe don't care
Universe don't care we have other
indications of time scales that are
different for example that of a dog
all right yeah you come home the dog is
jumping licking you in the face happy to
see you and all you did was forget your
keys you were just there oh you just
when I got the mail came back from the
mailbox right so the dog
is so fully living life think about that
wow humans don't carry on dogs do yeah
every day a dog lives
is like seven days to a human wow now I
have another reason to be jealous of
dogs no you could say that both ways you
could say one day onto a human is seven
days unto the dog right because we live
seven times as long as a dog but I'd
rather think of it the other way
that the dog lives seven days of life
in one of your days
wow and that's why it'll sleep when
you're not there but when you're there
it is all up in your face begging for
your food even though it just ate
looking all cute uh get one and get pet
get it stumped tummy rub so these are
two very different time scales and the
life forms are reflecting that I think
that makes sense because you go you take
them out for a walk in the morning and
then when you come home from work
they're just like you know let's go
let's go let's do it yeah come on get
ready let's go man it's been three days
so she walked me
what a surprise how could you leave me
here for three days man well because
that's half of one day right right the
morning to evening Chuck did the math on
that one wait did you see it was a
Saturday Night Live skit of when when it
came out that Wilt Chamberlain had like
thousands of lovers yeah okay in his
biography and no one believed it but
it's like but you're not Will
Chamberlain right so who who are you to
say it wasn't so Saturday Night Live did
a skit and it was called The Love
Diaries of Wilt Chamberlain it's so
funny so he's in a hotel room and a
woman shows up and it's like our eyes
met
and it was love at first sight where has
she been my whole life I don't know our
moments were so tender and so soft and
then it says six minutes later
we began to grow apart
that's funny
every five minute encounter had a full
full relationship in relationship that's
pretty cool yeah
anyhow so time scales you want to try to
get a sense of them and usually you have
to do that by putting them into another
kind of reference frame so one way to do
it is if you take 100 meters let's say
right it's a little longer than 100
yards it won't make much of a difference
for what I'm about to describe so take
100 meters that's more International to
think of it that way and we can ask if
the timeline of the universe
were placed onto those 100 meters
where would things happen
on that field
okay and I guess you know the Gridiron
Football they Mark out the 100 the 100
yards let's go back to yards here okay
100 yards let's map
14 billion
years into a hundred yards okay
Big Bang is right at the beginning at
one end zone okay right and let's keep
walking down
you have to go 10 20 30 40 50 60 70. now
it's going it's counting down to like 40
to 30. you got to go to the opponent's
30 yard line
before the solar system is born
wow
the universe has spent nearly two-thirds
of its life
without the solar system
to this day there are religious people
where people motivated by religious
philosophies who say that the conditions
in the universe are just right for life
just right for human life because at any
of these parameters been different then
we wouldn't be here
so it's perfectly tuned and I'm saying
if two-thirds of the history of the
universe there was no solar system
what does it mean to say that it was
perfect for life
that sounds really inefficient
season is perfect life you have life
going right away but no you have to
slowly make the heavy elements from the
Light Elements all that happened in the
first three minutes okay well you made
made hydrogen and then you start making
Stars After the Dark Ages the the James
Webb Space Telescope is exquisitely
tuned to look just at the end of the
Dark Ages in the early Universe where we
had matter and energy but no stars yet
they had to be made and then assemble
into galaxies and have enough of these
to make enough heavy elements to make
planets because planets have a lot of
heavy elements in them and they're made
in the centers of stars that takes time
we are second third generation star
system that made the Sun and we see
stars being born today looking deep
inside gas clouds when those stars have
planets in orbit around them all of them
made of the heavy elements that occurred
later so you got to get to your
opponent's 30 yard line before you even
see the solar system now you keep
trudging along you'd say well when when
are we you know when did life kick in
life kicked in pretty quickly after
Earth cooled down okay take a few steps
you have evidence earliest evidence of
life on Earth
microbial life how about life that
looked interesting how about anything
such as that okay well you got to get
down a uh down to the four yard line
the four yard line
single-celled organisms become
multi-celled organisms and the
multi-cell organisms can do things like
they have legs and antennae and and
eyeballs or early early versions of
eyeballs sensory sensors of what is
happening in their environment that's at
the four yard line
the four yard line keep walking
you keep going you keep going that what
okay well when do we get to human
civilization how about just Civilization
now how about no forget civilization how
about just troglodytes trunk cave
dwellers how about where are they
cave dwellers
appeared
at the near side
of the thickness of a blade of grass
at the zero yard line
so right before the next end zone yeah
you are one
thickness of the blade of grass
towards the end zone to find cave
dweller correct we're in the goal line
correct and now you move your waist
through the thickness of that blade of
grass and find okay the development of
Agriculture that's like that's
two-thirds of the way 2 thirds of the
way through the thickness of the
agriculture then you keep going okay and
then you get like Moses go half again
through the what remained of that you
get Moses and then Jesus and then
Muhammad and all of this in the last
one third to one tenth in that range of
the blade of grass that is at the end
zone after you traveled 100 yards to get
there it's Fourth and a tenth of a blade
and Grace
yeah so we're not sure is he gonna go
for it apparently the coach doesn't have
a lot of uh confidence in it they're
gonna kick it looks like they're going
to kick a field goals
they only made it to troglodytes
so what's what's the theory Neil when
things move like that that all of a
sudden just completely accelerate at a
ridiculous speed comparative to what
we've experienced through the that time
well so what happens is what
civilization did and the discovery of
science as a tool to shape civilization
we can have rapid progress or if you
don't want to Value judge the inventions
of science we can say we have rapid
change yeah you know you know 110 years
ago
horses was the way to go and a hundred
and a hundred years ago you couldn't
give away a horse that was a very fast
change in especially in cities or
agriculture take a while before they had
good tractors but point is yeah you can
have change but that doesn't that
doesn't get because it happens quickly
yeah it's sort of hidden in this
timeline you have to like zoom in and
expand it zoom in expand it zoom in and
expand it and only then do you get to
see what's going on in our lives in all
fairness to the change uh with horses it
was motivated by poop yeah
I mean that will that will speed things
up horse manure horse manure will speed
some things up right because there were
no pooper scooper laws that's right
your horse dropped some dump you didn't
get off and clean that stuff up you
that's it they didn't have some two-part
diapers they didn't have those they
didn't do that you just stepped in some
steaming horse poop there you go you
came behind so you'd have to zoom in on
this timeline to see where we are in our
modern civilization which has been so
significantly touched by the progress of
science so so I
I get that the point of this exercise
however is to see what we are relative
to the universe
and for those who say oh the universe
was created just for us
and all these stars are just for me and
the people or or Mercury's in retrograde
and Mercury is affecting my life
really really
look at this universe look at how big it
is look at how old it is look at how
many stars are in it
really
and so this transformation of a timeline
into a distance line
I think is one way to familiar to to
gain perspective on this and of course
we did something similar to that in
Cosmos first done in the original Cosmos
with uh andrewian co-writer with with
Steve Soder and of course Carl Sagan
they have what's called The Cosmic
calendar
what they did was there was they took
time
and they put it into time right they
took the history of the universe and
laid it from January 1st to December
31st okay and so that's a little
different we did time into a distance
they did time into a ton why did they do
that because we have words for those
time units we have things called months
we have a year we have months we have
weeks we have days we have hours we have
minutes we have seconds
so because we have ready-made
vocabulary to describe much smaller
units of time than a year it became very
helpful to represent it in that fashion
so it's a matter when was civilization
just like a minute ago or to have to
recalculate that to get the numbers
right but we have words for this and
when was when was you know the
automobile invented like a fraction of a
second into the past and you say damn we
ain't been here any amount of time at
all right so the things like the James
Webb Telescope well that make us think
about the calibration of time and the
universe in a different way or just it
literally Enlighten us
excellent question so all it will quote
simply do is take us to a place in time
forgive me for using a place and a Time
reference in one sentence take us to a
place in time yeah where
galaxies are being born so we get to
fill in the storyline so you go back to
the previous end zone so the James Webb
Space Telescope if I just did a fast
calculation in real time uh we'll go
back to the seven yard line
oh wow
the real question is who's returning
this kickoff because that will make a
big difference in how long that
timeline really is yeah but think about
it I mean it's a lot of universe between
one end zone and the other but what that
means is we will have access
to almost the entire playing field
almost the entire timeline of the
universe right from seven yards up to
100 yards this is an extraordinary
Triumph of modern astrophysics
enabled empowered by brilliant engineers
that enabled us to to work with this
telescope to begin with
all so that
science can tell you you ain't so
special
science is really good at that yeah
now what we really want to know is be
able to look in the other direction and
predict the future which we do with some
I can tell you about solar eclipses and
ten hundred a thousand years from now at
what exact minute the sun will disappear
as viewed from any point on Earth's
surface I can do that all right some
other predictions are a little fuzzier
but still have real foundations to them
like humans are warming the Earth
all right and that can melt the polar
ice caps and flood our coastal cities
all right oh you want to know what
minute that will happen the met the
calculations are are harder than it is
for an eclipse to give you the exact
minute that's going to happen but I can
speak statistically of the likelihood
that storms are going to wash over your
beachfront property so there you have it
Gridiron timeline
and and it's just it's some fast car you
just take ratios uh it's a it's an
exercise in ratio taking yeah it's so
simple Gary so simple so all I did just
I can tell you so so James Webb Space
something is observing galaxies maybe
back to a billion years after the big
bang so you take the ratio of 1 billion
to 14 billion all right and what is that
fraction then you multiply that fraction
by 100 yards and that'll tell you how
um
how many yards you back at Seas I get
about seven yards and you know why uh we
don't have to do that because you did it
for us no yes
you're like calculating it's fun with
calculations
we probably don't have as much joy doing
it as you do so anyhow uh that's it for
this installment
of explainers Neil deGrasse Tyson here
keep looking up
[Music]